hablemos sobre las ondas y la definición
tradicional de onda es una perturbación
una perturbación que se propaga que se
propaga
a través
de un medio
a qué nos referimos con perturbación y a
qué nos referimos con medio pues podemos
poner algunos ejemplos bastante
sencillos imaginemos que aquí tenemos un
charco y voy a dejar caer una piedra en
este charco y todos sabemos qué es lo
que sucede cuando cae al charco en
cuanto cae al agua empuja esa agua hacia
abajo la cual luego vuelve a salir hacia
arriba y se comienza a propagar empuja
al agua que se encuentra a un lado y esa
agua se hunde y vuelve a surgir y ahora
tenemos una perturbación que se propaga
estos anillos que comienzan a radiar
hacia afuera y se propagan a partir de
donde deje caer la piedra y nosotros
podemos ver cómo se están moviendo
podemos ver la cresta de las ondas
moverse hacia afuera y esto es una
perturbación porque originalmente el
charco estaba completamente plano pero
después lo agitamos lo empujamos hacia
abajo luego se fue hacia arriba esto a
su vez empujó al agua que tenía juntos
arriba abajo arriba abajo y viajo o se
propagó hacia afuera a partir de el
punto en donde se inició la perturbación
crece que tenemos una perturbación que
se propaga a través de un medio cuál es
el medio aquí pues en este caso el medio
es el agua y nuestra perturbación al
inicio fue esta piedra que comenzó a
mover al agua pero después esta agua
comenzó a mover oa perturbar al agua que
se encontraba junto a ella y así
sucesivamente por lo que esta
perturbación se propagó o viajó a través
del medio y podemos tener otros ejemplos
de esto imaginen que yo tengo una cuerda
bastante larga que sostengo aquí es una
cuerda bastante larga y esta cuerda se
encuentra en reposo pero está atada a
algo en la pared
y voy a comenzar a mover mi mano hacia
arriba y hacia abajo que es lo que va a
pasar si yo hago este movimiento una vez
que va a pasar primero voy a ver este
bulto en la cuerda más o menos así y
unos momentos después se va a ver así y
voy a estar generando una perturbación
que es esta curva que se está viendo
aquí que se va a estar moviendo a la
derecha en este caso cuál es el medio
pues el medio es la cuerda y qué es lo
que está pasando aquí cuando yo estoy
sacudiendo la cuerda la estoy moviendo
hacia arriba
estoy perturbando a las moléculas de la
cuerda que se encuentran justo junto a
mi mano y esas moléculas a su vez van a
jalar a las moléculas de cuerda que se
encuentran junto a ellas y así
sucesivamente de manera que tenemos este
bulto que se está moviendo
así pues aquí tenemos dos ejemplos de
ondas que son perturbaciones que se
están propagando a través de un medio y
podemos tener otros ejemplos
uno de ellos son las ondas de sonido que
es lo que ocasionan las ondas de sonido
bueno imaginen que tenemos muchas
partículas de aire por acá
todas se están moviendo y rebotando
sorprendentemente rápido pero si las
perturbamos si tenemos algo que comience
a comprimir las por ejemplo las
moléculas de aire de por acá se están
comprimiendo muchísimo algo está
ocurriendo que las está comprimiendo y
lo que van a hacer es que éstas van a
rebotar con aquellas partículas de aire
que se encuentren junto a ellas y
nuevamente tendremos una perturbación
que se está propagando a través de este
medio
en este caso el medio es el aire y ahora
que ya hemos visto algunas nociones
clásicas de las ondas
pensemos en algo que es un poco más
misterioso y esto es la noción de la luz
nosotros sabemos que la luz tiene
características de onda la luz puede
interferir pse entre sí tenemos varios
vídeos en donde hablamos acerca de la
luz por ejemplo si yo tengo una barrera
más o menos así con dos pequeñas ranuras
y si yo dirijo hacia
luz una forma de pensar en esto es que
estas ranuras son el único lugar en
donde se puede dar una perturbación lo
que ocasiona que la luz se propague a
través de cada una de ellas
aquí solo estoy dibujando las crestas de
la onda o los puntos máximos y ustedes
verán que en donde coinciden dos crestas
va a aumentar la luz o se va a tener una
interferencia constructiva y si
colocáramos algún detector aquí
podríamos observar las interferencias
constructivas o los puntos brillantes de
la luz y los puntos oscuros así que
definitivamente la luz se comporta como
una onda y ese es sólo uno de varios
ejemplos que podemos tener de esto pero
si es una onda apoyándonos en esta
definición clásica pues tendría que
propagarse a través de un medio y aquí
cuál es el medio bueno tenemos luz que
viene del sol le llamamos luz solar y
aquí aunque normalmente tratamos de
dibujar o tendemos a dibujar el sol de
color amarillo en realidad su color es
blanco el tono amarillo que vemos es por
nuestra atmósfera así que aquí tenemos
al sol por aquí tenemos a la tierra
aunque este no es un dibujo escala y de
cierta manera su luz
nos llega a través de casi 150 millones
de kilómetros para ser exactos son 149
millones 600 mil kilómetros acaso esto
es una perturbación que se está
propagando a través de un medio y
durante mucho tiempo las personas
pensaron que así era
es decir bueno está viajando esta luz
tiene propiedades de onda y su rapidez
es la velocidad de la luz entonces
pensaban que debía existir un medio por
el cual se propagaba incluso las
personas le dieron un nombre a este
supuesto medio y vale la pena escribirlo
porque es bastante curioso le llamaban
éter y por cierto podría ser un buen
nombre para una banda este lumínico
lumínico y la idea era que aún en el
vacío del espacio teníamos esta
sustancia
este éter lumínico por el cual se estaba
propagando la luz por lo que tendríamos
una perturbación en este eterno lumínico
y lo que haremos en los siguientes
vídeos es probar esto tratar de
verificar si este es el caso ya que es
interesante la idea de si existe el éter
lumínico no vamos a estar estacionarios
con relación a este test ya que nuestro
planeta orbita alrededor del sol el sol
orbita alrededor del centro de la
galaxia por lo que no hay manera de que
estemos nosotros estacionarios con
respecto a este test lumínico y si no
estamos estacionarios con respecto a
este éter lumínico entonces podríamos
detectar cómo se comporta la luz cuando
se encuentra en dirección del éter o en
dirección opuesta relativa al movimiento
del éter con respecto a nosotros por él
y aquí los dejo con este misterio de la
ciencia en donde definimos a la onda
como una perturbación que se propaga a
través de un medio y vimos varios
ejemplos de esto lo vimos tanto para el
agua como para la cuerda pero acaso
existe para la luz este éter lumínico lo
ponemos entre signos de interrogación